hello there
and welcome uh to the latte sponsored
virtual tools enhancer training
experience
um my name is jessica and in a minute
you'll you'll meet
kirsten as well and we are excited to
come before you and present you with
this information
so latte is an organization made of
trainers
lots of people in the lab animal
industry and
our purpose is to exchange and share
information wisdom and experience
and so some of those things we plan to
share with you
on today
so i will first my name is jessica stuke
i have a educational background bachelor
of science in laboratory animal science
from north carolina a t
state university and i am currently the
education and training manager for the
division of laboratory animal resources
at duke university in durham north
carolina um
i have been in the industry over 20
years with a variety of experiences
a variety of species and i'm
happy to now be a place where i can help
others learn and train effectively
uh kirsa hi everybody
my name is kirsa pokrisky and i am the
managing director
of the training corps at the university
of michigan
i work in the unit for laboratory animal
medicine i've been in laboratory animal
science for over 20 years now
and in training for about 18 of those
and i'm excited to be part of latte and
be part of lab roots to provide this
presentation today
awesome so
our goal for this workshop is to make
sure
that our students which they're you
right now uh we'll explore
a variety of training tools which can be
utilized to train
uh trainees that you're at your
prospective organizations
virtually um when when face-to-face
training
cannot be achieved um we clearly are in
a different time
right now with uh covet 19 and so some
of these tools
can be incorporated into those times now
these are some
awesome things that you can use for a
mixture
of in-person and virtual
learning
from our opportunities we want to make
sure that we demonstrate the use of
various software applications
um and the purpose is to hopefully in
keeping with the three r's to reduce the
use of live animals for training
and to increase learning engagement as
well as to identify some ways in which
these
software applications can be used to
improve training in a lab setting
so as we're going through as we're
talking uh
you can just let your mind wonder and
explore
and run well with all the endless
possibilities in the ways that
these this information can be used
welcome again to this presentation and
i'm excited to have you all here too
um so our for our introduction today um
we are going
going to go through a bunch of platforms
and software applications that can be
utilized to maintain the three
r's as a critical component in training
and setting up effective training so
training in a virtual setting
easily allows for reduction of animal
use refinement of techniques
as well as replacing animals by
utilizing other training tools instead
of live animals
training involves three basic components
content connection
and application while the content varies
connecting with the students based on
their individual learning styles and
demonstrating how to apply the skills
virtually continues to be a challenge
recently
learning challenges have exacerbated by
the emergence of
coven 19. kova 19 has motivated all of
us to think outside the box and create
virtual training tools in order to
provide training without sacrificing
quality while establishing a method
that employs a 3rs this presentation
will delve into various virtual training
tools that can assist
training coordinators and other
laboratory science professionals to
administer training to a varied
audience while also providing an
effective way for an audience to learn
laboratory animal science
topics so some of those topics may
include student engagement and ownership
and self-paced learning so some students
may find it easier to learn
by themselves and self-paced personnel
safety it enhances that by providing
students with the opportunity to learn
from home
instead of going into the work
environment ineffective use of time
no there's no travel required when
you're training virtually
and class times may be shortened because
of
virtual training and there's also a
component of better time management
so keep that in mind when you're
training your students it may be
important for scheduling or working
through
their your training you may be able to
shorten those times and create a better
schedule for
training and there's also opportunities
for learning
so there are various opportunities with
all the training tools that we'll be
presenting today such as videos
pictures discussions
various scenarios and role plays that
you can provide virtually
and then this also enhances um
all of the learners capability to engage
by touching on all those learning styles
of
each student in class
so a workshop outline today we're going
to go through various
virtual training topics and tools and as
you can see there are a few of them are
going to review today
i'm going to go over the first few and
then jessica will take over later on
and to go through some additional topics
google documents google documents are an
interactive shared document system
and can be incorporated into your
training students are able to move
pictures
words or answer questions within the
same document in real time
students can visualize other students
actions within the document in real time
as well
google documents include the following
options we have word documents we can
use excel
we have google forms that you can
utilize as well
and we found that google forms could be
used for virtual escape rooms
so if you want to create a fun activity
for your students you can use a google
form to create
an escape room and can be designed in
google forms
to enhance learning of a topic
and today i'm going to demonstrate the
use of a google document that we utilize
in class
for our rat users and we're going to
show the relationship between rats
and the components of an inside of a
rack cage and how students interact with
this document
so here's our application of a google
document in a virtual training class
so using google documents in this
activity the student will find the arrow
in the picture that corresponds with the
student number
then they will drag the correct cage
component from the class toolbox at the
top
to the answer box this is how we run
virtual training
for animal handling restraint workshops
this minimizes animal use
and refines the way we train handling
and restraint
when students do come to handling
restraint class they already have
an opportunity to provide
the animals with a safer environment to
learn
because they understand the components
of a cage and they'll also understand
the components of handling or straining
an animal appropriately so we can
maintain animal welfare throughout the
training period
our next component that we're going to
talk about today
of virtual training is utilizing zoom
and webex so
zoom and webex are cloud-based video and
audio conferencing software that allows
co-workers
friends and classes to collaborate in
real time
additional features of zoom and webex
include
chat break rooms and file sharing
these features can enhance any training
class the chat feature allows for
students to ask the trainer questions
throughout the meeting
and for the instructor to and students
to share links
break rooms can be utilized to divide a
large training audience into smaller
more manageable groups smaller groups
provide an opportunity for everyone to
participate in their own learning
by answering questions and participating
in smaller group discussions
file sharing allows for the instructor
to share important files with the
audience and can enhance the learning
experience
polling options are also available and
questions can be launched at any time
during a zoom
or a webex meeting polling questions
allows students to answer questions in
real time and answers are shared with
the group to further the discussion
zoom and webex also have the capability
for the instructor
to enable students to control their
screen in some learning experiences
this may be very important
the application number two this on the
left you will see
that the polling option in zoom is
one of the there's a question a couple
questions that are asked to the students
and the students will click their answer
and then you can share those results
with the students
as well as to your right you have the
opportunity to allow
others to take control of your screen to
place
um answers in an answer box
or move pictures around if they need to
or watch a video
so there are various opportunities for
folks to utilize zoom in webex
in their training as well as a trainer
to
increase learner engagement with you
know setting up zoom poles either ahead
of time or during the class if you find
there's a good discussion point
you can actually set up a zoom time zoom
poll right in real time
and i also wanted to mention that zoom
and
webex are frequently available in all
situations so i know university of
michigan we did not have zoom before
march happened so when march happened we
were able to then have zoom and we can
do a whole
bunch of fun stuff in zoom so we're
really excited about using zoom in our
training
and we do so frequently
pull everywhere pull everywhere is
software
that utilizes live audience feedback to
answer questions both free text and
multiple choice in addition poll
everywhere can be configured for
students to participate
in creating word clouds to enhance
learning experiences
a free limited access version as well as
more enhanced
paid subscriptions are available for
poll everywhere
this is an example of one of the pull
everywhere questions
that we have activated for our one of
our student audiences
and if this is a ranking tool so you can
use poll everywhere for many different
situations and variety of other types of
questions so multiple choice
questions and free text box so this can
be utilized in a big
large audience or a smaller audience
and like i said this is free a free
application so it's fairly easy to use
and set up
and then you can ask your questions in
real time for your students in your
class
and this can be through a mobile device
or through
uh your desktop
now i'm going to turn it over to jessica
so next up is a web-based product called
slano
profilo is a web-based application that
allows students to participate also
in real-time polls and questioning
answer sessions as well as
quizzes so students can join the final
meeting
via a link or a qr code and one of the
one of the cool things about final is
that you can create
your own hashtag uh in order for
your students to join and they can also
participate using their mobile phone
so this can be a tool used for
small groups or very large groups i've
used it with
a zoom training session of 45
attendees it also has presentation and
results labs that can be
embedded or integrated into other
programs and software
like microsoft powerpoint and teams as
well as google meet
and so once you um download
the system you won't have to travel
back and forth from the smito
web browser to microsoft powerpoint
the the program will integrate into
powerpoint
presenter view and so this is a paid
service but there is a basic account
that is free with limitations of course
that limits the maximum number of
participants as well as
the maximum number of polls that you can
have per event
so we're going to take a look at an
example of one of those
results so in the presentation that we
did initially
we asked our icebreaker question which
was where are you joining us from
you can see in the left-hand side of the
screen it says to join
you can go to the website and that was
our specially designed hashtag which was
martin's tv
and participants were able to join their
cell phones
and then when this first question was
presented they will put it in their
answers
so this is the result word cloud
of people participating and where they
were participating from
so this could be uh you asking a
question about
anything and getting everybody's
feedback
now one of the things about friday i
will tell you that when people
when you sign in initially as a
participant
you're asked for your name so if you are
using this tool in a smaller group
you can um generate reports after that
if you're interested
in the answers for students specifically
in case you want to follow up with them
accordingly okay the next thing we're
going to talk about
is called thing link so thing link is
what i like to call a discovery themed
interactive tool
that's used to engage students by
offering information pop-ups
on files or images and videos that you
upload now those images can be
still or they can be 360.
pop-ups are expanded to reveal text they
can reveal images
videos or links and england can be
shared via a link
or an embedded code so if you have a
hosting site or
if you have a website
then you can just put you can embed the
code there and then people can
participate uh there
is a free education and teacher account
with unlimited number of images and
videos you can upload
and a thousand views per year um so
those viewers do not have to have any
type of account
only the person creating has to have an
account and that account can be free
so we're going to take a look at a thing
link that
we've set up here um this is the picture
of
an animal and as you can see
that there are yellow buttons
in in the real if you were viewing this
on a browser
those buttons would kind of be pulsating
a bit
but the buttons represent a different
type of
file so there are to the far right there
is a plus sign
and when you hover over it it will
expand
to this text box that you see here so
you can use this
if you are trying to um
you're trying to get the student to
receive a large amount of information
or allow them to discover uh information
within a picture or within a video
so there are like i mentioned you can
use text
you can also use video so that bottom
left play button would open another
window that's the video
there also in that top left there's a
picture icon and these icons can be
changed the color can be changed to your
liking
and that will um open another window
that pops out a picture to offer a
little more detail or content
to what what the the teacher wants to be
obtaining it at that moment
okay so the next thing the next tool is
called
tablet now some of these tools i will
tell you that they
they offer you
some of the same capabilities but
there's always it's always good to have
options so tagline is a software
um it's pretty much like a web-based
post-it note
it allows students to offer free text
responses on a virtual minimum board
posts can be arranged in a variety of
ways to categorize or to connect
responses they can be placed on a
timeline and you're asking students to
indicate what happened in a certain
place you can also upload your own
picture background
and have them almost do in reverse of
the last tool we talked about
uh where you post the picture and then
you ask them to put
a radio point for what what's happening
in certain places a patent can be shared
again via links
qr codes embedded they can be used on
the classroom
or they can be exported in jp or pdf
there are a number of security
permissions that will allow
only certain people that have a link to
view
as well as if you decide to require a
password you can do that as well and
this one
is free to use so an example
of padlet here we have a training
session this is again the one that we
presented um
people have the freedom to put their
name if they like one of the other ways
that i've experienced sadly
is um i was taking a trainer trainer
class
and before class the instructor wanted
us all to get to know each other
so she asked us to go to her tablet and
to
include a picture in our bio so it was a
way
for us to interact and get to know each
other before we even got into class and
of course that was
class pre-closing
on the next tool that i'm going to talk
about briefly here
is articulate storyline so there are a
number
of uh software that are used
to design and publish interactive
learning courses
and our tv the storyline is the one that
i i prefer
um there's also adobe captivate and
there
there are some resources online that
give you a comparison
between the two they're very very
similar and so
um the design interfacing of articulate
storyline is
very similar to powerpoint which is
another reason why
i like it because you can design your
online training
module in powerpoint and then import it
into storyline and it will maintain
background maintain
font maintain all those things and then
in storyline
you would just add the interactive
pieces of it
um if you wanted a talking head or if
you wanted
uh to add some quizzing elements you
could do that
and so courses can be published from
storyline
in a variety of ways you can publish it
into a learning management system
lms or you can use web distribution
or even video file as an mp4
so our tpu storyline is a part
of a larger suite of products called
articulate 360
which includes storyline rise studio
review and peak and i'll just throw a
plug out there for peak
because peak is the tool you can use to
screen record
i mean it's been extremely helpful for
me trying to
show some students how to navigate our
safety website
or to navigate through some of our
learning management system
so i can just record things and share
share with them how to do that
they can actually see me doing it with
my screen
this is a subscription-based
product and it is 499
for one user per year but it is well
well worth it
so this is one of the examples of a
storyline
um a storyline
produced this is um on
their website and it they have a variety
of them
in the community and you can find them
at community.articulate.com
um and this is one that someone designed
it's about eighth grade um history i
believe
but um it's a jeopardy game and it is
completely interactive so
you would click on arithmetic for 100
and it would it would give you a
question and you would answer so this is
another way
um that you can design interactive
training
within storyline
i will turn back over to cancer
thank you jessica appreciate that so our
next
tool that we're going to be utilizing
today is called qualtrics
so calltrix is a software application
that allows organizations to collect
feedback data and analytic reports in
order to improve processes or training
oftentimes in training we want to
evaluate our training and how well
it is received and how effective it is
qualtrics can be a way to do this
in addition it is important to consider
having various evaluation
points throughout training qualtrics can
also help collect data
related to level 1 to level 4 training
evaluations
utilizing the kirkpatrick's training
evaluation models
in at university of michigan we use
qualtrics for a variety of purposes
we use qualtrics for pre-tests before
training
we use qualtrics for post-tests and
trainer evaluations
and we also use utilize qualtrics for
training request forms and in which you
could set quotas
so if you only want four people in a
training session
once that four four people have signed
up for that training that option goes
away
so qualtrics has a variety of
opportunities to be utilized in training
so this is an example i'm showing you
here is a post-test provided to students
following a class about mouse handling
and restraint the
results from this post-test can be
compared to the pre-test with the same
questions
and i can test the effectiveness of this
training based on the pre
and post-test questions so this is very
helpful
when i'm reviewing event in
effectiveness of training and training
applications and data
i can utilize this data from pre-test
post-tests evaluation of training
as well as i manage a group of nine
so i can manage the trainers by pulling
their evaluation data from classes
as well this is very helpful in variety
of aspects for
training purposes and i really am
excited
and get excited about using
qualtrics in the application of training
now it is important
to know that in qualtrics the
application
is a very very good help desk
so enough oftentimes in the past when
i've used culture because there have
been a variety of things we wanted to do
in qualtrics
now instead of me just fumbling around
qualtrics and trying to figure it out i
will ask the help desk and they will get
back to me immediately
so they are very very helpful and even
some things that they couldn't
perform in the application they actually
changed their application
in order for us to be able to perform
that thing that we wanted to do that
they couldn't do previously
so that was very helpful and their
customer service is fantastic
so if you're going to use evaluation
tool qualtrics is one of the evaluation
tools i would definitely take a look at
in review here's our review of our
objectives
we demonstrated the use of various
software applications
in order to reduce the use of live
animals for training and
increase learner engagement and identify
ways in which software applications can
be used to improve training in
laboratory setting
so there are many ways to engage your
audience while designing training
virtually
the applications listed here are just
some of the ways in which this can be
achieved
i would like to challenge you to design
training utilize one or two of these
applications
evaluate the effectiveness of your
training approach post training
and compare your results to previous
training on the same subject
to see what your results are it may be
exciting to see what kind of
results you get from instituting some
virtual training options like we've
offered here
and um please tell us your results if
you find out that this worked really
well for you please let us know
or if you have another application that
they you utilize that we didn't cover
here
please let us know how how it works and
how well it works and how it works that
would be great
thank you very much